we are inundated with requests emails
invitations and outright appeals every
day
how our day turns out is entirely
contingent on these factors
the commitments that we are going to
fulfill the goals that we will
accomplish are entirely driven by the
decisions we make it's a simple fact
that you can never be productive if you
take on too many fronts
that's why the art of saying no can be a
game changer for productivity
however saying no can be totally
uncomfortable but if you learn how to
say a gentle note you can reclaim
control over your work schedules and
what you want to do with them and that's
precisely what we are going to learn in
this video today but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit that bell icon to never
miss an update from simply learn you
must be thinking what's the big deal
about saying no
to begin with it can hurt upset or
disappoint the person to whom you're
saying no and that's never a pleasant
task
secondly if you want to work with that
individual again in the future you want
to have a positive connection with them
and expressing no incorrectly might
damage that
so to assist you in preserving your
professional relationships we have
compiled a list of the top five tips
that can help you stop pleasing others
and learn the art of saying no
compassionately
moving forward we will iterate through
these tips one by one the first tip on
our list is find your yes
before you can improve your ability to
say no you must first understand what
you are saying yes to and what
consequences it brings you see every
chance you turn down with a no is
actually saying yes to something else
something you'd rather do or something
more essential to you in the long run
otherwise you won't be able to utter
know when the pressure is on when you're
unclear about what exactly you want
that's why the first task we want you to
do is think about your yes when you're
under pressure to say so and you feel
capitulation is simpler than taking a
stand
for example consider the scenario where
you've been invited to join the csr
initiative of your company
if you opt to say yes to this
opportunity you might be spending your
weekends working on campaigns
also you'll hardly be able to give any
time to your family
concentrating on this reality will give
you the confidence to say no and keep
your priorities in order the next tip we
have is to refrain from saying direct
yes
if you have doubts about the opportunity
you have been presented with and are
feeling driven to say yes we recommend
that you abstain from going to a direct
yes
you should ask for a day's time to think
about the opportunity before responding
after a thorough self-reflection on your
obligations you'll be able to figure out
if the presented commitment is a
feasible addition to your calendar or
not
sleeping on your decision will
definitely offer you the opportunity to
think about the best method to say no
the third tip we have is sandwich a no
between two yeses
sandwiching a no between two yeses makes
your no more appealing
it's also a wonderful method to explain
what you've already committed to
for example if your boss asks you to
work on the weekend but you have family
obligations that you cannot break
in that case you should explain these
obligations to your boss this will be
the first yes
then you can explain how your family
prevents you from working on the weekend
it will highlight your no
after that you can finish by confirming
your commitment to the company and your
work by asking if there are other ways
that you can contribute to that business
front
this will be the final yes
this method of saying indirect no will
help you maintain your work relations
while valuing your time
the next tip on our list is do not use
limp phrases make no mistake no is a
powerful world
often we yield swords of yes slashing
into every opportunity that comes our
way even if it's not meant for us and
usually in the process we get frustrated
at ourselves
you must recognize slashing swords is
not the only way to fight
sometimes you'll have to defend yourself
with a shield and the word no is a
shield that can barricade you from those
unnecessary obligations
however to do that you must yield that
shield confidently
avoid statements like i don't believe i
can or i am unsure
using weak sentences instead of
expressing no is frequently seen as a
yes
hence when the time comes to say no
simply say
no
the last tip we have for you is be
prepared to repeat yourself
the greatest thing you can do if you say
no and the other person pushes back is
to say it again it's much easier to
accomplish this if you know that it is
often necessary
if you provided an explanation with your
initial response you can either repeat
it or just say no
it is your right to say no to any
request and you'll often need to be firm
in order to have your intentions known
that's all we have for today i hope this
video is helpful to all of you out there
and i wish you all the very best thank
you for watching the video and stay
tuned for more from simply learn
hi there if you liked this video
subscribe to the simplylearn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here